what's that you say you need
recommendations in the best games to
play an xbox game pass well you're in
luck july has been packed with loads of
games for all walks of gamers so here's
eight games you can play on the service
right now
[Music]
that's right power wash simulator let's
face it games are outlets for our most
inner power fantasies and maybe i'm just
sleeping in my old age but as someone
living in an apartment in a big old city
i feel that my life is robbed of the
chance to rid my patio sidewalk
lawnmower and garden gnomes of earth's
filth the game is simple unadulterated
and to the point and its simplicity
lends to some incredibly relaxing and
meditative sessions even better it's
multiplayer and cross-platform with pc
so you and five of your friends can
cleanse the world of its filth as a team
this game has been a great way to just
unwind from the day recently i've just
been booting it up with my partner and
mostly just chatting about our days
while monotonously cleaning lawn
furniture or drawing obscene things on
the roof so yeah it's great
but maybe you need something more than
the simple act of cleaning the world
maybe you already have a backyard and
are cool enough to own a sweet power
wash gun even more maybe you just don't
want to clean things you want to smash
down walls and install toilets and wire
a house and furnish it and then sell it
if that's the simulator you're yearning
for then house flipper is the game for
you like power wash simulator there's
something extremely relaxing about
tearing a house apart to redo all its
inner workings paint the walls and
vacuum up cockroaches or maybe i'm just
becoming an old person that likes
mundane old person like things and maybe
xbox game pass is just trying to really
hone in on that old person market and
well in that case they're doing it very
very well except that i'm not
that old of a person um
yeah
anyways you can burst through walls with
a sledgehammer so that's sweet
let's escape from these boring life
simulators that i can't help but love
and i mean let's literally escape escape
room academy is exactly what it is an
academy filled with rooms to escape race
against the clock to solve puzzles
uncover clues and unravel riddles in
order to escape room after room and best
of all you don't have to do it alone in
fact i'd highly recommend you do it with
a friend if you can
even better it offers split screen co-op
and while i think playing alone is
absolutely totally fine there's
something truly frenetic about sitting
right next to someone as you try to
figure out the puzzles together the game
encourages you to have paper and pen
available when you're playing and i
absolutely support that many of the
puzzles i was solving involve me taking
notes and decoding all sorts of things
or having to memorize a long pattern
playing co-op also allows one player to
solve one puzzle that'll reveal the
answer to another making communication
really rewarding and fluid
let's change the pace to something a
little more dramatic with as dusk falls
it's an interactive drama that throws
you into the entangled lives of two
families that crossed each other's paths
under extremely unfortunate
circumstances what unravels is an epic
that spans across 30 years with each of
your choices cascading into many many
different outcomes it's honestly quite
mind-boggling one of the shining
features of the game is its multiplayer
giving up to 8 players to be able to
make decisions and form the story
together even better players don't need
a controller instead they just need to
download a free app and then use that to
vote on what happens next being able to
sit with others and discuss moral
dilemmas that can at times mean life or
death is exhilarating as it is stressful
but thankfully as dusk falls rewards
players with a vast amount of
possibilities and gives you a chance to
glance over other routes you could have
taken and where your decision lands with
other players around the world as dust
falls features some of the best
mechanics in the genre and is bolstered
by a unique and distinct art style as
well some pretty convincing performances
it's a dramatic ride and one filled with
plenty of surprises
if interactive dramas aren't your bag
but you still want a game where choices
matter and evolve more than quick time
events and decision making then road 96
is certainly worth a shot you step into
the shoes of multiple teenage
hitchhikers attempting to start a new
life and run away from an authoritarian
nation you'll hail down drivers take
buses or even steal cars to get to your
destination whatever it takes the stops
you take along your journey are
procedurally generated you'll explore
them find supplies get money and talk to
its many many characters the game
describes itself as an ever evolving
story driven adventure inspired by
quentin tarantino the coen brothers and
bong joon ho that is quite a lofty
amount of very good inspirations to have
on your procedurally generated journey
you'll engage in moments of action drama
and wacky encounters to add some levity
to an intertwining story about escaping
an authoritative world
[Music]
enough of the dramatic open road of the
united states of america let's go to a
fantastical sci-fi realm a place in
which you are born falling from orbit
into a world of gods and the
unbelievable and torment tides of
numenera
this is a single player crpg with a deep
thematic story all of which is
underpinned with philosophical tones if
you're a fan of pillars of eternity then
you'll feel right at home with this game
as they were both built using the same
tech additionally in good old crpg
fashion it's filled with branching
choices and narratives driven by complex
dialogue trees that make it ripe for
replayability torment is from inexile
entertainment the developers behind
classics like the bars tale as well as
the wastelands series which by the way
are all on game pass if you've played
those games and you enjoyed them then
why not dip your toes into the cerebral
sci-fi world of torment tides of
numenera
giddy up on your steel horse and burn
some rubber in motogp 22. we've talked
about watching gnomes flipping houses
crime dramas and escape rooms but you
best believe i wouldn't forget about you
racing folks this is an immersive and
authentic racer featuring 120 riders and
over 20 circuits to shred through if
you're a motogp fanatic 22 lets you
relive the iconic 2009 grand prix and
step into the boots of racing legends
and experience their races first hand
but you know in your living room with a
controller instead and you know what
maybe racing isn't the only thing you
care about maybe you want the realistic
hands-on experience of managing a team
well you can do that too in motogp 22.
yakuza is back on game pass that's right
after leaving a few months back yakuza 0
kawami and kwami 2 have returned so if
you slept on them the first time well
here's your second chance to boot up
these melodramatic crime romps if you're
just hopping into this saga and don't
know where to begin i suggest jumping
right into yakuza 0 which is a prequel
to the entire series or maybe i just
have a bias because that was my first
yakuza and i absolutely love it but if
you're a traditionalist and want to play
them in which the way they were released
go with koami which is a remake of the
original 2005 classic the yakuza series
is an immaculate balance of serious
crime drama and off-the-wall quirkiness
it's the type of story that'll have you
gasping in shock and holding back tears
one moment and then burst out into
laughter the next when you get
sidetracked from its many many goofy
side missions
and that's that july for game pass gave
way to my power fantasy to power wash
while peppering in some serious drama
with as dusk falls and road 96 there
really is something for everybody
alright folks let me know if you liked
any of these pics in the comments and as
always make sure to leave
recommendations below for other game
passers alright till next time see ya